it's a good rivalry the nats and the
mets over the years generic fetty fifth
career start against new york betty has
a great sinker up to 95 miles an hour
also throws a good cutter curveball a
changeup and a four seam fastball has
been very good against right-handed
batters this season
it's in a hopper here comes josh
zimmerman
at the end of the scoop with the glove
3-2 and lindor pulls it hard and ryan
zimmerman has it two ground ball outs
always a great sign for eric fetty early
in the game
to left
well hit not well enough for them
schwarber has it approaching the wall
and on a couple of grounders and a fly
ball eric fetty a great start and
there's joey le casey and uh his last
four starts he's only given up three
earned runs so all of these nats have
seen him before but only briefly
oh cherv is in there for a call third
strike and schwarber is out on three
pitches
and curve in there for a call third
strike so lucasie gets a couple of
strikeouts on an opening inning so a
base runner for billy mckinney
and he grounds that one down to
zimmerman the throw to second for one
turner back to first too high
and it's backed up harrison mckinney
took a turn he's gonna be tagged out
oh
oh my gosh that the first base umpire
adam hamari giving him a pass and he
took one step towards second and that's
all it takes right there there it is
that's it
hamari wasn't watching wow
up their meeting and they're not going
to change anything
upstairs
that's how you get a contact guy get him
o2 and then something that's not
reachable
3-2 runner going check swing top of the
second is over that tumble
and zimmerman takes a fastball for
strike three call so lucasy has struck
out three of the first four batters all
on call third strike
and gomes chases a high fast ball and
lucas is on an early roll he's struck
out four of the first five batters
rollicking from the start has retired
the first five here's josh harrison and
he hits one of the ear to left field
coming in toward the line is dom smith
and he puts it away to retire the side
runner going
did he get him yes
you see so many young players they want
to go reach out and tag the base runner
but watch how trey turner picks this
bill and tags the base and gets mason
williams to slide into his glove this is
picture perfect
swing and a miss on the cutter
fetty three strikeouts through three and
with one out eric fetty could be
sacrificing giving schwarber a chance
the second goes neato and he airmails it
and the ball's in center field robles
gets up playing third
safe
robles at third fetty at first and
schwarber takes it low ball four and the
bases are loaded for turner
and the first pitch turf hit down a
third vr with the step and the throw and
he turns the double play on the side has
retired
to his right turner on the run the jump
the throw
brian zimmerman hardly had to move it
was so on target
that's lined the other way and dom's got
the mets first hit since the second
inning last night
so after 11 innings without a hit
the mets finally break that string
runner on the move
and he tried to pull it so he rolls over
the grounder
brick release by jordy mercer and that's
what it took to get it
ryan zimmerman got caught guessing and
looking first time up
ryan zimmerman left center
it's going to be in there and ryan
zimmerman continues to get a knock or
two every time he plays
very short lead and he's not going and
gomes grounds a double play ball right
at lindor the turn by giorni for the
routine six four three double plays
struck out his first time up one of
three strikeouts for fetty
that's nice to the left center field for
a base hit for g or may employees stay
in the curve ball and the mets have
their second hit
runner on the move
on target out is the call
as jan gomes refuses this year to let
runners get to second base almost every
time
swing and a miss on a big curveball now
the pitch swing and a mess struck him
out on a fastball up to 95 miles an hour
running the outside williams down
swinging
3-2 on the attack with a cutter
strikeout number six for eric fetty
whose high is nine
and that's vr twice tonight
he's neo1 with two outs
chopper sounded like that foot as it hit
the plate go do it yourself eric fetty
and keep running to the dugout and give
somebody a souvenir and go get a
breather you're having a nice night
buddy first time since 2019 that lucasia
has faced a batter
in the third time through the order for
his career third time through the order
and beyond they're hitting 309 against
him
swinging a miss he got him with the
chair for the second time
strikeout number five for lucasie his
first since the second inning
trey turner finds a hole
[Applause]
on soto calmly takes his 41st walk of
the year
fourth most in the league
and now two on for ryan zimmerman
and here comes luis rojas yes
so lucasie goes deeper into the game
than he has at any point for the mets
he'll leave in a scoreless game in the
sixth and leave two men on for miguel
castro
and it's grounded down a third a chance
for two vr in a second guillory on the
first double play side retired metz
turned their third double play of the
night eric fetty mosh pitches this year
the same as he just threw 98.
ground ball
nobody to take a throw at second so trey
turner only had one choice the 6-3 for
the second out
mercer gave with it perfect throw
let's take a stretch shall we
[Applause]
recall
and we have an angry hitter
we talked about the strike zone of
kerwin danley tonight he hasn't liked
the high pitch much but that one got
plenty of the bucks
schwarber trying to get it to trey
turner here in the eighth
he will
cal schwarber on for the second time
2-2 coming to turner
struck him out ball gets away from neato
he recovers it makes the throw on target
side retired and here's brad hand in a
holdem situation
swing and a miss on a big slider
two outs
and alonzo to right soto there how about
that for a quick ninth inning
only thing better would have been if a
save was attached to it edwin diaz will
come into a tie game on the road in the
bottom of the night i'm a bit surprised
that diaz is in
juan soto great take and he takes the
walk
spins the bat and he's ready to roll
down the first
makeup call possibly
this one definitely catches the
inside corner of the box there ryan mr
clutch
bottom of the ninth soto running
zimmerman base hit
one soto is gonna be on third with
nobody else
a wonderful at bat for ryan zimmerman
you got your tower buzzed by a hundred
miles an hour and what do you do to
follow up stay on the slider
use every inch of your back
and find a hole in the right side
career
he is two for six
against edwin deals
[Applause]
off the mess